Alright folks, welcome back to this showing off stuff.
Alright, so today we went through the process of watching and analyzing the opening price
on ES and I mentioned on Twitter that I was interested in this old high back here.
That's largely linked to the fact that we had a gap when the session started again last
night in my local time about 6 o'clock.
We gapped down and then it just drifted lower, had a small little rally in here, SMT divergence.
I'll show you that in a moment, but in here we have market creating relative equal highs.
It broke down.
I gave you the fair value gap live this morning on the live stream, walk you through the whole
business of running out the sell side and the opening gap on Sunday which is over here.
So I don't have that on my chart so let me just drop that on real quick.
If you don't mind me working as I go, I don't want to be doing any more edits than I need
to and I don't think you mind me doing it in front of you so we can see what I'm showing you.
Alright so the market trades down below the sell side here and into the Sunday gap opening.
We traded through it all the way down to another fair value gap.
Hits that there, comes back up, runs back up into the opening range, drops once more
into an order block, rallies, takes a short term high, retraces back down into another
order block.
Let me stretch this out a little bit so you can see a little bit better.
It's not as cluttered as it is now.
And we worked off this order block, this order block which you'll see when you get into the
five minute chart.
It's a little bit cleaner here and here and rallying up into the levels I was mentioning
on Twitter this morning.
So I'm going to drop into a five minute chart.
Okay and there's the fair value gap I gave you live.
Beautiful delivery.
Look at the low on this candle right here.
Right up here, look at this value right here, 39.26 and three quarters.
This candle trades right back up to what value?
The high now on this candle, 39.26 and three quarters.
Folks that is absolutely perfect.
That's perfect price delivery.
Okay.
I know I'm kind of known for the Forex market showing things like that to the people, that
type of stuff.
It originated really with index futures, bonds and index futures.
So in the 90s I was utilizing these same tools.
I know it seems like it just came out of nowhere recently because I've talked about it but
these things have been under my control, my ownership if you will, for about three decades.
So it's nice to be able to share them obviously with all of you and it's very, well I guess
the word is fulfilling to show it to you, to walk you through it live so you can see
what it is, what it looks like.
And yes, I have a lot of people asking me, why don't I give trade signals?
Can I run a trade signal room?
Please, I will pay you.
Can you do this and can you do that?
No, I'm not going to do that.
I don't want to be in another paid service type thing.
I'm sick of it.
I don't want to deal with that no more.
I can make all the money I ever need trading.
And to be honest with you, I don't really need to do anything anymore anyway.
I'm padded out.
So just enjoy the fact that I'm wanting to teach.
I love teaching.
I love sharing with you.
And I know it is helping a lot of you.
So just let that be the economy between us.
Okay.
I like doing it.
You like receiving it.
It doesn't cost you anything.
So there you go.
So when we hit this fair value gap, it broke lower and then once more returned back up
into it.
Oh, not into the fair value gap, but up into that range here and then broke and I gave
you a small little imbalance and we'll look at in a moment.
We traded down into the Sunday gap.
I mentioned the lower end would be this time the level of the watch.
And so if we went down below it, come back up, it'll act as what?
Resistance.
It does so here.
We'll look at it in the lower time frame.
Drops lower, once more hits the old fair value gap I showed you before we dropped into the
five minute.
A little bit of consolidation ahead of lunch.
Typical retracement during the lunch hour all the way back up to the opening range.
Broke lower, small little swing low broken back to a rebalance.
And also look what it's doing here, folks.
It's going back up into that old gap opening on Sunday trades up into it.
Act as what?
Resistance trades lower down into an order block.
Big downhandle right there.
That's the one over here.
Hits it starts to accumulate rallies up.
Back above what level?
Here, I'm going to make Sunday's levels really, really obvious.
It's going to be obnoxious, actually, because I want you to see what was going on in my
mind as I'm watching price.
Okay.
Price goes above the opening gap, or gap opening rather from Sunday, then trades back down
into it.
See that?
Hits it, rallies, falls short of what?
The relative equal highs over here.
Retraces, where does it trade down into?
That gap opening again.
Now we're at the discount low.
It rallies, comes back down in, fair value gap, trades into that.
This is a 15-minute order block.
Rallies and what's it go to?
The 39.52 and three-quarters level.
Here is it, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful, beautiful.
In the afternoon, it became a lot better.
In the morning, it was sloppy.
So when I say things are sloppy, it just means that it's not really giving you a whole lot
to work with.
You have very few options, and you have to know exactly what you're looking for, i.e.
what I was giving you this morning.
This area here, watch how it stayed open, and it stayed open basically the whole thing.
This is sloppy, even though it's a nice delivery, it's not giving you all of the mechanics of
entry, like this one here, this one here, this one here, and then run to the objective
I was drawing your attention to today.
So the morning, while yet it was still potentially profitable, and I was able to call it for
you live, that really wasn't my choice session, because I didn't have a real clear view on
what I wanted to see.
This morning, one of the followers on my Twitter feed, a lady asked, why was I talking about
39.53 level?
I rounded it up one quarter point above this level, and the high comes in at 39.54.5, so
off by one and a half points, so our handles.
So I was more interested in the run to that level, versus just going down to the Sunday
Gap opening, or the old London Open lows.
There are trades there, obviously, and I can see them coming, it's not a matter of missing
them because I don't know that they're there or forming.
My interest really lies with what is the setup that I'm liking the most, like what is it
I'm looking for specifically, and the level I gave you, that 39.53 level, I want to see
a run up into that.
So we had to come down below, and then back above Sunday's Gap opening, and then it treats
it as a dynamic support resistance level.
Did you just hear ICT?
That's blasphemy.
He just talked retail.
That's a cuss word around here.
Well, I'm talking about it in a way where you'll understand it.
So the opening gap on Sunday, if you put it in your charts and just plot it across the
entire week, you'll see that many times there's a lot of valuation around that gap.
So it'll be treated as a dynamic price level.
If it's above it, look for it to act as support.
If it's below it, look for it to act as resistance, and if you can find a swing high, for instance,
we have these here.
We traded down.
Okay?
If it's going to trade down into the Sunday gap opening, look for it to run above here.
There you go.
You don't need to have this level that I pointed out.
This is enough relative equal highs, and relative equal highs are here.
So I've taught you how to find those buy-side liquidity pools, but I taught you today with
this lesson using that Sunday gap opening and just extending it through the entire week.
Sometimes the week will just run away from it and won't really come back to it, but in
weeks where there's consolidation, like FOMC, we had that to deal with for this calendar
week, and those types of events create these choppy range-bound markets that don't give
you the real clean take-off one-way directional move.
You have to know how to trade in these environments, okay?
So obviously my tools do very well in this environment, too, but let's go down into four-minute
chart.
Actually, let's go into a three, and now let's go down to two-minute.
There it is.
I forgot what time frame I was looking at.
Good grief.
All right, so we dropped down to a lower time frame.
Here's a two-minute.
You can see we have a fair bay gap here.
I mentioned how I didn't want to see it come back up into that once we moved away, go back
and watch the live stream recording that's on YouTube, unedited.
It's exactly as it was done at the time.
You can see I was fumbling around, had no idea what I'm doing.
Before I get any further in this lesson and lecture, understand this.
I am not buttering you all up to do these a lot.
I don't want to do them a lot.
They take a lot of my time.
They distract me from my own trading and my own personal life.
So I understand that doesn't make you feel good because you had a good time today and
maybe you learned something yesterday, too, with the other live session.
But I showed you what it looks like.
I showed you how you go into the marketplace and you read it, and I'm going to leave it
up to you, the viewers, to decide whether or not if these things work.
You don't need me holding your hand.
The worst thing that I could do is sit down with you just a few times a week or even once
week.
That would create such a codependency on me that it would not help you.
And to be quite honest with you, I knew as soon as I did this, I would get complaints
and emails and things.
We need you to help us take live trades.
We want you to do that.
You're being selfish.
You're being ignorant.
You are self-centered because you won't tell us when to get in, when to get out.
I didn't do this for that type of feedback.
I only promised I would show you that I could show you the things before it happens, that
way you can see what it looks like, and there's nothing that's required to trick anybody.
I mean, either it's going to work or it's not going to work.
But you have to be in front of the charts doing these types of things, and failing is
part of that.
That's how you learn.
These are opportunities to grow from that.
So anyway, I think that is it.
I want to go back up to the 15-minute time frame and talk a little bit about this area
up here.
That gap, I think that is where we're going to be drawing up into because this is, in
my opinion, not going to be left open.
Okay?
So they're going to want to trade back up into that.
There's missing data here.
Okay?
There's an actual gap.
So it'll want to draw up into that, and to what price level, I'd like the low on that
candle.
Okay?
So if it was going to be a perfect delivery, it would go right to that candle's low.
But I'm not expecting perfect.
I'm not suggesting that at all.
But if we go above this area, that means we're probably going to go into a deeper run on
the daily.
And let's take everything off here.
So we're likely to run this high here, and we have an overblock there.
So the low at $4,000, so that's something to consider and watch going forward for the
rest of the week.
I may be wrong.
You know?
It's just something for you to go into your charts and start studying and looking for.
I think I have one bit of business.
Oh, let's go back into...
Let's go into a five minute chart.
All right.
I was watching Hannah on her YouTube channel, and I don't know exactly offhand what market
was.
Maybe it was Canadian dollar, but it was a Forex pair.
I don't need to have that on the chart to explain what I saw her doing.
And some of my students, when they first come in to the fold, they do this type of thing
too.
They will look at a range like this, like here to here, and they'll measure that range
low to high to find the 50% level, and then use that over here for a discount.
That's not how we do it, OK?
If we are looking for a short, in Hannah's example, she was looking for a short, you
want to look at the price lag that drops, and this is going to be the reverse of that,
OK?
So this might be a little confusing, but just reverse the logic, and you'll understand.
I'm sure Hannah will follow along.
So from the low here up to this high here, if we're looking for a long to get above these
relative equal highs, or use that 39.53 level I was calling for, or making reference to
this morning, this low up to this high, this is what you'd be doing, OK?
So if you're looking for it to go higher, you're going to need to draw your fib from
a low up to a high.
That dealing range from that low to that high, we're waiting for an anticipated retracement.
So the retracement's going down to and below 50%.
Now this becomes what?
A discount.
So you can be hunting a long at this level or less.
If we're into a fair value gap, that's good, OK?
The same thing is done here, because it has not taken this out here yet, just fell short
of it.
So if we take the fib and just anchor it to that high and run it to here, you can see
here's 50% of this dealing range low, this dealing range high, and it drops down to a
discount, OK?
You're looking at expansion swings, OK, or impulsive price swings in the direction you're
trying to trade.
You don't want to use a price lag from high to low measuring something that you're trying
to go long on, but you don't want that.
You want to be using the impulsive price swings that go in the direction you're trading.
Then it retraces down in below 50% or added into a fair value gap.
Then you can probe that as a long and it rallies up.
So I just want to kind of clarify that.
I wasn't sure if she was aware of what she was doing, but if she wasn't aware of that
now, she knows.
So that way, all of you have had the benefit of learning through her interactive study,
which I'm absolutely loving.
I'm loving it.
I wish more of you would do it, and as long as I had time to sit down, usually it's on
the weekends that I get a chance to catch up to stuff like that.
But I'm loving the Thailand vibe.
I'm loving the booboo kits and not so much the food poisoning.
Sorry for that, but hopefully this has been insightful to you, Hannah.
Hopefully everyone else has got something from this as well.
And I'm sure I'll be back again, Lord willing, on Thursday, and until then, be safe.